- Yo, what up vlog?
Here in Chinatown in London.
♫ We're unstoppable
On my way to London.
On the plane all day actually so
interesting day for the vlog.
I don't know if a lot of you guys know,
this is one of the only pieces of content
I made during this era.
It was the airplane rant.
Very high in the air, back from London
headed to New York City.
I'm gonna watch it, see if
it inspires another rant.
Five years later.
Just sat here and read
100 emails from people
that were making 40-50K, 30K.
Read Crush It!, read Thank You
Economy, got inspired by me.
But I was a spark.
I was the one that had that
insane thing that I have in
me that made them say "Hmm."
You know?
Things that make you go hmm.
'80s reference, sorry.
But then they had it in them.
And so when I make this video,
what's coming from my heart right now is,
maybe you're watching this and saying hmm,
maybe I need to hedge.
If you work from 8:00 p.m.
to four in the morning,
will your dreams come true?
No.
You might not be good enough.
You might have not
picked the right product
but are we living in a world,
2012, that's so much better
than your parent's and grandparent's
and great-grandparent's generation
because assholes like me can make videos
when I'm 30,000 fucking feet in the air?
Yes.
And because of that, and
because of those opportunities,
and because we're networked in
a way we've never seen before
and because sending an email to 100 people
and one will answer and
give you a shot matters,
because of that opportunity,
because of 2012,
I beg you, I beg you to take a shot.
Oh.
You good?
Oh I knew what I wanted to talk about.
First of all, hey everybody.
Airport Gary.
♫ Airport
♫ Airport Gary
- This is how I sign by the
way, people have been asking.
If you've gotten a book from me,
I sign my signature
then I do this in there.
Selling.
Just came back from two
days with Ryan Harwood
and selling VaynerX, PureWow, VaynerMedia.
The competition conference
I'm doing at Wine Library.
Nope, not a fare.
I just think everybody is now.
He said Sanjay, I'm just like,
if anybody says anything, I'm like, "Hey"
The competitor conference,
the Wine of the Month Club,
the digital corks, the Four D's.
It's been a fun kind of four
or five months of selling
for me which is, not where I normally am.
And it made me think
of something which is,
the way I do branding, I
sell so infrequently that
I think some of you that are
watching me the hardest core
need to hear this which
is, it's okay to sell
especially if you believe in something.
Like if you believe in
what you're selling,
and that's what I'm spending
a lot of time on now,
trying to spend more time
on really getting to a place
where I really believe in stuff
instead of just passive not creating,
so I wasn't selling
'cause I didn't believe
you know and just letting
everything come to me.
But as I create these events,
Vayner experienced a lot of
events, very big on events,
events are so valuable, just
watching the Four D's crew,
its value and how it's
impacting their business
for $10,000, right?
I know you're getting the emails.
The Wine Club, like $150
worth of wine for 55 bucks.
I've just locked in November's,
it's gonna make all your
Thanksgivings ridiculous.
The conference, $500 two hour session
in my stomping grounds,
good deal compared to like
other conferences that I speak at.
But you're getting the wine for free.
Or you're getting the talk for free
and you're getting the wine.
I'm very fascinated because
I'm putting more pressure
on myself to create things
that I really believe in,
which then allows me to sell more
and I just think for a lot of you
selling the ask, the right
hook is very difficult.
You're passive, you like
the idea of feeling good
about giving out content, this and that.
When you believe in
something, you can sell it
and you should put more
pressure on yourself
to create things that you believe in.
Biggest problem is so
many of you sell shit
you don't believe in,
you're just doing it for
the fuckin' money and
you're gonna fuckin' lose
and that I don't like.
Let's go to London.
In the spirit of always
trying to add little hacks,
tried something new on this London trip.
Usually we go late,
land
and it's like a whole tough day and so,
went early today to London,
land and now it's late here.
Not as late at home.
My plan was to do a lot of work, land here
and then go to sleep and
just be in a good rhythm.
Unfortunately, haven't been
sleeping much as I'd like.
By the way, real quick, always
getting six, seven, eight,
but got some fives and sixes and around,
got a little tired so,
had a glass of wine and conked out.
It didn't work out but here's the point
why I'm sharing it with you,
need to try different things
and different patterns.
London wasn't working,
I wasn't as productive
and I was always very, very tired so
tried something new.
Not exactly executing my game plan but
the fact that I'm trying something new
makes it our y-positive.
10:14, the competitor business conference,
next post on Snapchat,
swipe it up, check it out.
Yo, what up vlog?
Here in Chinatown in London.
Driver explaining it to Jordan and D-Rock.
11:00 p.m. at night.
Same old, same old.
I wanna wrap this up very simply.
As much as things change,
like fuckin' Shake Shack
in the middle of London,
things stay the same and
for me that's very simple.
People innovating all around,
voice, Instagram, all that shit but
it's the grind, it's the message,
it's doing the right thing,
it's the context of the content,
for the next 20 years, I'm
gonna say the same shit.
The platforms are gonna change,
your attention's gonna move
like that bag just moved but,
the game's the fuckin' same.
See ya.
So I think when I get the praise,
it's what the fuck does
that have to do me?
When I get shit on, I'm like
that's on me and I'll fix it.
And I think those,
I said it really quick but
it's fuckin' accountability,
it's accountability and
ownership when you suck,
and it's passing on the
credit when you fuckin' rule.
And that's it.
And that's me and and that's my makeup.
And that's why I'm winning in life
and that's why I'm always gonna win
because when you're
fucking 100% accountable
and you know your shit, you're garbage.
When your 100% accountable
when there's an issue,
and when you pass on the
praise when you're getting it,
you become fundamentally
undefeated, unbeatable.
I'm straight up unbeatable
because my head will never
get gassed up enough ever,
when I'm getting it good and,
and I'll never believe it's me,
and when it's bad, I'll never point
the fuckin' finger to anybody else.
All you fuckin' fingerpointers,
pointing everywhere, everybody's
fuckin' pointing fingers,
pointing them everywhere.
It's everybody's fuckin'
fault but yourself.
Your country, your
environment, your parents,
your school system, your boss, your aunt,
your fuckin' circumstances and of course,
and of course there's tragedies and crimes
and child abuse and real bad stuff.
I'm not saying it's not real.
I'm saying for the 95% of
you, it's a mindset thing.
Perspective, perspective's everything.
I'm grounded in my perspective.
Never too high, never too low.
It's about them when it's good,
it's about me when it's bad.
That's me.
That's what I got for you.
That's where I'm at, that's my mindset
and I never waver.
It's a fucking 100%, never fuckin' waver.
I have my bad days,
but I keep that shit to myself.
("Unstoppable" by The Score)
So what's going on?
Let me answer some questions now.
What can I help you guys with?